the january 6 committee has just hired a
former producer of good morning america
called james goldston he'll be
overseeing the committee's prime time
hearings on thursday night so the show
trial now has a production crew and of
course we'll be covering that in great
detail on thursday
by arresting peter navarro they're
hoping to shut up one of the most vocal
critics before it begins but peter
navarro is a brave man he's not shutting
up he joins us now for his first
interview since being arrested he is as
we told you a former senior white house
adviser and the author of taking back
trump so america why we lost the white
house and how we'll win it back he joins
us now peter navarro thanks so much for
coming on um
how was this
allowed
this is so outside the bounds unless i'm
missing something and i hope if so
you'll correct it this is so outside the
bounds of how a civilized country
behaves did you see it coming if not how
do you think this was allowed to happen
uh certainly i i saw it coming we have
entered really dangerous unprecedented
waters
tucker i was in a position
where a partisan
committee
uh has weaponized the investigatory
powers for the purpose
of uh preventing donald trump from ever
getting back in the white house
uh they subpoenaed me illegally
and i i was faced with the untenable
choice of upholding
executive privilege which was not my
privilege to way that's donald trump's
privilege to waive so i did my duty to
the president i did my duty to this
country and here we said and and the
civil suit i filed tucker i hope will be
historically important because there's
really two constitutional issues here at
stake the first with this weaponization
of congress's investigatory powers is a
clear violation of the separation of
powers in our constitution the
legislative branch is not
supposed to be the judge jury and
execution i heard one of your
commentators there when you played that
clip the purpose was to punish peter
navarro that's not their role that's the
judiciary's role so that alone
is sufficient to render what they have
done illegal and therefore what the
department of justice did
illegal but the bigger issue here tucker
and this is where
the department of justice and committee
were so disingenuous i assert executive
the executive privilege prevents me from
from
complying with their subpoenas and
instead of going to talk and negotiate
the privilege with donald trump as the
law requires they went into this
fanciful and absurd notion that biden a
sitting incumbent president could strip
his immediate predecessor
of executive privilege and me
a staff member to the president of what
the justice department itself as you
pointed out
has absolute testimonial immunity it's
absurd on its face wait can every step
along the line go ahead well i have no
doubt that it's unconstitutional and
it's clearly the abuse of power but i
just want to get to the center of it
which is january 6. this is the january
6th committee you saw liz cheney in that
disgusting ridiculous fawning interview
say this it's also chilling did you have
anything
at all to do with january 6th
no no it's it you you had that exactly
right and and what what you and i have
now both said and which is absolute fact
is that the the mission of that
partisan witch-hunt kangaroo committee
which is unduly authorized and not
properly constituted and has no subpoena
power they have only one mission to
concoct a fake hoax around january 6
based on criminal charges against trump
to prevent him from running for
reelection
in in taking back the white house in
2025 january that's all
this is about and the idea look tucker
this was i i you you said it i live
right next door 50 yards from the fbi on
the wednesday night i sent an email to
patricia eloy the deputy
attorney and said look i'm seeking a
modus vivendi here i'm stuck between a
rock and a hard place let's see what we
can do i gave her the name of an
attorney i told walter giordano the fbi
agent who'd come banging on my door the
week before hey walter
i'm here just call me whatever you need
you don't need a bang on my door they
chose a different route they didn't call
my attorney instead they went with this
shock and awe terrorist strategy
yeah let me go to the airport and then
take me with five agents like i'm an
al-qaeda terrorist
rock me into a car and the next thing i
know i mean leg irons handcuffs strip
search i mean it was not without comedy
i mean at one point the fbi agents
couldn't find the door to go into where
i was supposed to go the fingerprint
machine didn't work but but you know
people do not want to sit in solitary
confinement and leg irons denied food
denied water denied an attorney and yet
this is what we live in i mean i studied
kafka in college it took me like till i
was 72 to understand kafka
we
you can't arrest people for political
reasons it's very simple we've invited
every member of that committee on the
show all of them are too cowardly
kinzinger cheney cowards but i just
think this is a huge change in the way
this country operates and i wanted to
note that and extend our sympathy to you
peter navarro thank you and godspeed
thank you for your coverage sir
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight